[Music]
and just ate it yes just eat it that's
not the right tool I mean you take two
take two it's already past time
submitted by Houston number one Oh
diners at a Michelin star restaurant are
told to stop instagramming their food
shut the [ __ ] up
why damn I was gonna agree but never
mind I would've but I I don't trust a
Michelin system anymore you snobby ass
bucks but go on
tell the story well that's why you don't
want them to Instagram food because
you're going there based on Instagram
stuff cuz other people are saying how
awesome is by taking these pictures oh I
thought I was ruining the experience I'm
just going cuz Michelin stars is
supposed to be like better than Yelp
like or if it has a Michelin star it's
gonna be the best cuz it's worth going
to that country for this restaurant
I hated it and like three Michelin
restaurants or for three and then only
one is three and that one I had better
how about that wasn't good complaint you
mean I complained to the restaurant yeah
yeah so so just be like oh this dish is
too salty
return it I'll tell you the first time
we were in Las Vegas and we went to Joel
Robuchon show like 300 bucks or so
finally don't wanna spend that money he
made me spend that much was my first
time experiencing anything like that so
I thought I was too peasant to even
comment on something I never tried
before so I was bigger I thought my case
puzzles are ready for that [ __ ]
[ __ ] try to feed me foam what
the [ __ ] is this gastronomy [ __ ] you
so upset his words can come cuz it was
between two things you guys chose the
other thing I think it was only me one
other person that told the other yeah
you and Tommy had sadness Tommy it was I
oh you know we also got the prefix menu
for the group so that's different we
didn't order off the regular menu
it don't matter it's a Michelin star
restaurants
McDonald's is McDonald's whether it's
the dollar menu or the [ __ ] full
value for a full meal it's still good
don't think iterated on that one dish or
whatever I'm just mad only one we spent
$300 each yeah
in order for you to get a Michelin star
restaurant it's based on everything on
everything service food everything
education environment the presentation
of vine was on point though yeah and the
bathroom seat god [ __ ] gold faucets
is [ __ ] oh [ __ ] we on the black napkins
they were so soft yeah and the water was
bomb that water though you get at a
normal cafe in France or whatever it's
just yeah it's just regular water man I
am so upset at Michelin because you guys
are not the [ __ ] know-it-alls I don't
trust you anymore
people have preferences for their food
and you know it sucks too because
sometimes when people eat food they say
what they think other people would feel
about it versus what they actually think
you know what I mean
so they'll say oh because this thing's
expensive don't start describing what a
food is and this literally it's like you
don't know what the [ __ ] you're talking
about that's like the food bloggers now
they're like oh the notes of blah blah
did you talk to this chef how the [ __ ]
do you know [ __ ] you know and that's
just like that food culture nowadays I
don't like it I like ghetto food Avenue
26 tacos shoutouts to them
I like ghetto food to you I want to know
that when I go there i'ma get about six
tacos for six dollars and diarrhea
afterwards I go here if I'm gonna spend
300 bucks right I want it to be like
this is made out of gold and truffles
it's expensive things inexpensive fresh
ingredients hey this is this is
Madagascar monkey you know like this is
this is some potato that was handcrafted
by a craftsman elf for some [ __ ] you
know like they hired a bunch of French
waiters that came out with the accent to
make me feel like I'm more rich than I
really am and then the [ __ ] big dim
sum basket of bread I'm like I can't
even pronounce the bread I mean it done
they give me the roll call of like the
thirty breads that they had because I
had to fill up
bread and I'm like I spent 300 bucks on
this [ __ ] Brad dude yes for the
service every time after that you to me
Lee would come and brush the whole
family that's cool hella clean too good
how was it working hundred dollars well
Clara's birthday she had a private chef
and it's like Oprah's private chef and
then she gave us like a six or seven
courses now Halloween yeah dude that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] bombed oh man I gotta
say though I walked away thoroughly
satisfied and it was like decent portion
suicide smaller portions but you have
lost seven or eight courses but it was
quite delicious like Wagyu beef with
like this pea puree there was oniy with
like this gelee of some sort see that
makes sense
I would pay 300 for that I got [ __ ]
pumpkin foam oh my god yeah they had
light like congee you know like the rice
porridge with like truffle and like gold
flakes of [ __ ] outside god damn this is
[ __ ] amazing dude I walked away with
an experience I was like soxhlet blew it
my poopoo that [ __ ] was crazy anyways
back to this thing here Thank You Clara
your birthday was amazing happy birthday
happy birthday
so no water side in is a British
restaurant that has continuously held
three Michelin stars since 1985 Sam so
they put up a sign that says no thought
does bleep and they're saying that the
co-founder here Michael Oh Roo he he's
just like so over he's like I hate
seeing people taking photos like why are
they doing that maybe once during the
meal you want to take a little photo of
something because it's unusual but what
about the flavours a picture on a phone
cannot possibly capture the flavors so
now they're banning photo taking in the
restaurant I think that's up to the the
purveyor to decide if that's what they
don't want that's fine there's like no
shirt shoes no shirt no service type of
[ __ ] yeah in my personal opinion times
have changed so it's a little bit
backwards yeah I also have standards but
I also like evolving with times too
because I don't I think if that person
pays for the food and they want to take
a picture of it there's there's yeah if
as long as it's not disrupting people
like if they're [ __ ] pulling out a
tripod and [ __ ] and in there like
[ __ ] put it on lights in my explain
come on man you [ __ ] up the whole
environment but if it's a if it's a
[ __ ] phone and it's like this like oh
okay
but some people get really into it where
they're like oh wait wait can you like
hold the spoon a certain way and like at
a certain height and then like does it
be like oh yeah yeah hold on let me just
move things in and then like they'll
take five minutes to take one perfect
photo and your food is already cold I
can see both ways I can see where it's
like it's not a big deal but then I'm
like if there's a restaurant and you
want your food to come out a certain way
and you're like are you consider
yourself an artist I can see what it's
like you want your heart to be consumed
the way that it should be yeah not
consumed with the eyes consumed with the
tank as I say it's up to the purveyor
like I think it's it's his world and
you're paying for his service so if he
says this is the way I would like you to
try it then then you'll either [ __ ] with
it or you don't maybe you just have his
entire restaurant is really dark and
dimly lit be like no flash there's a
there's a ramen spot in Japan where you
can't even talk go in there yeah I shut
the [ __ ] up and you just eat and I think
that's pretty cool to where you just you
go in there with your friend and you're
not even out to whisper to each other
I like Hamas sushi in Little Tokyo
because people aren't allowed to take
pictures yeah because it's literally
they make the sushi you eat it and you
get the [ __ ] out oh yeah remember we ate
there by choppy logging you've got in
trouble got in trouble but I was cool
and then he even apologized he look I'm
sorry that I couldn't that you can
record any video but that's our rules oh
my that's perfectly fine it's your
guys's establishment you do whatever you
want I actually like it because I'm
there for a purpose I'm gonna try some
stuff too and it's so small - it kind of
gets in the way of everything so I
understand you know so this is no camera
no you can't even talk on your phone in
there if you talk on your phone you have
to walk outside yeah which I like so I'm
kind of like that - like when I make
food for her or whatever like it as soon
as I'm done making food because I know
when it's gonna taste the best you gotta
eat well I'll tell my dad you gotta eat
like anyone that's there I mean yeah
turns TV off what I really got I don't
want to make the food and then people
come at their convenience and now it's
not as it's best tasting form so I can
understand where they're coming from
yeah yeah so shop the walk are a lot of
people pissed about this and they don't
really talk about the response it's just
the fact that they did it yeah cause
like for these restaurants - you're
actually not going there to eat food
you're actually there for an experience
yeah you know for these Michelin star
rated restaurants the experience was
horrible
there you go well you know and I think
that's the difference - there's a reason
why they have seven set courses because
they're trying to take you through
something
art you know so if you kind of look at
it in that perspective it's not a
mcdonald's or it's not even like a
regular restaurant were you going there
just to get food that has its purpose
that's the type of retro sign light but
obviously for them I think like they're
offering something different so just be
mindful of that and then if you don't
like it you gotta [ __ ] with it yeah I
mean that's all so that's true it all
depends cuz I see restaurants as going
into different worlds yeah looking Jiro
the sushi man you can't talk and
everything's like strict that's how you
want he wants you to enjoy his stuff or
that other restaurant that as soon as
you walk in and get insulted oh yeah
Dick's or something or whatever yeah
there's one out in [ __ ] what Santiago
no [ __ ] Boston yeah there's that
barbecue joint where they give you a ton
of peanuts and you just throw the
[ __ ] shells all over the floor the
other one where you walk in if you're
wearing a tie they they cut it off and
they pin it somewhere how cool I didn't
hear about this yeah what would you guys
do in your own restaurant like a weird
quirky rule thing or it's like if you
come here and this happens this is what
happens to you I don't know about
gimmicks but I think food wise I would
want a restaurant where all my favorite
things around the world is offered in
one place so it's kind of mix and match
in color and weird okay kind of yeah
it's but not a buffet like it'll be the
it'll be good quality so it'll be like
fried chicken but also be like like
Bhutan or it'll be like Hawaiian stuff
or you know just random is just you
could order everything but it's my taste
I'm the DJ right so on the menu it's
like I curate the the content
it's just Joe's buffet right this one is
just like oh it's an actual menu yeah
yeah I got you oh my gosh you don't be
like food of the day no it's a Hong Kong
style cafe
as the UI chili cheese fries be chopping
we have everything that I like
[Music]